foreign
welcome to this new video by simply
learn before we start consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply La so welcome to the era of
Limitless possibilities where data and
computing power converts in the
boundless Rhythm of the cloud in today's
fast-paced Digital World cloud computing
has revolutionized the way we store
access and manage data from individuals
to large Enterprises cloud computing has
become an essential part of our everyday
lives powering businesses fueling
Innovations and transforming the way we
interact with technology and this opens
a large number of doors for aspiring
cloud computing candidates there are
various rules within the field of cloud
computing including Cloud architect
Cloud engineer Cloud developer Cloud
security specialist and Cloud operations
manager among others these roles involve
designing implementing managing and
securing cloud-based solutions for
organization the job market for cloud
computing professionals is robust with
many organizations actively seeking
skilled talent in this field cloud
computing careers can be found in
various Industries including technology
Finance Healthcare retail and more
providing diverse opportunities for
employment a cloud computing is
estimated to grow by 14 cagr from 2023
to 2030. an average salary of a cloud
architect is 22 lakhs per annum in India
whereas in U.S it's one twenty five
thousand dollars annually so if you
intend to become a cloud architect and
Excel your career then join us on an
exhilarating Journey as we unlock the
magic of cloud computing where the
dreams become reality and the sky is the
limit get ready to soar into the future
of computing with cloud computing as
your trust companion fasten your seat
belts because we are about to Embark an
awesome inspiring Adventure through the
clouds let's get started with the number
one certification on our list post
graduate program in cloud computing this
postgraduate program in cloud computing
will help you to become an expert in
designing planning and scaling Cloud
implementations the key features of this
program include eight times higher
interaction in live online classes by
industry experts 40 plus Hands-On
projects and integrated Labs Capstone
project in four domains Caltech ctme
postgraduate certificate and more with
this you will be gaining the skills like
cloud provider selection application
migration performance testing Cloud
workloads identity access management and
more your profile will get highlighted
among the recruiters with the tools like
Amazon ec2 AWS Lambda Azure container
services virtual machines Amazon
dynamodb SQL Azure resource manager and
much more so what are you waiting for
get the complete course details to
enhance your profile find the link in
the description box hear how happy our
Learners are with the course check the
simple learn reviews Link in the
description box now introducing you to
another exciting course on cloud
computing which is Caltech cloud
computing bootcamp this bootcamps comes
with the skills like cloud provider
selection Auto scaling Disaster Recovery
web services and API Cloud migration and
deployment and more not only the skills
but you will also learn most
eye-catching tools in the cloud
computing namely AWS Lambda Azure
container services Azure Cosmo DB
cloudwatch DNS AWS security Center our
Learners have experienced great hikes
and Industrial offers check the simply
learned reviews from the link in the
description box moving to the course
number three which is azure Cloud
Architects Masters program this program
will help you to master Azure Cloud
architect Technology Solutions
implementing workloads and Security in
Azure creating and deploying apps in
Azure and securing the data in Azure
some features of this course includes
industry recognized certifications
projects and Career Services job as a
services and more by the end of this
course you will have a stronghold on the
tools like Azure container services
Azure functions Azure disk storage DNS
and more hurry up and Android now don't
forget to use the discount coupon ytb 15
for this course find the course Link in
the description box at number 4 we have
AWS Cloud architect Masters program this
certification will make you an expert in
Amazon web services as it covers the
architectural principles and services of
AWS with this you will learn to design
and deploy highly scalable and fault
tolerant applications on age AWS and
gain the expertise in the tools like AWS
IM Amazon elb AWS cloudwatch Amazon S3
and more best part about this course is
you will get a discount by applying the
code ytb E15 nothing can stop you from
becoming Cloud expert enroll the course
file the course Link in the description
box coming to the last course on the
list which is cloud architect Masters
program Cloud architect Masters program
comes with the features like Master
certification 40 plus in demand skills
and 25 Services 16 plus real life
projects and more find the course Link
in the description box so here we have
come to the end of top 5 certifications
in cloud computing we will meet you
again with another video on Career
guidance and upskilling soon if you like
this video share this video and don't
forget to subscribe to Simply learn
thanks for watching this video
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here